ninety percent of the conversations in
advertising land is about how it used to
be or AI is coming nobody pays attention
to today and today is the only thing
that matters a million things are going
to change television as we know it is
dying in front of our faces it's all
going to be streaming connective TV AI
is going to accelerate at scale over the
next 10 years and take away a lot of the
things that a lot of us do every day so
that we can do better things everyone's
like they're going to take our jobs
nothing's going to take your job if
you're willing to adjust and do
something that's more valuable tractors
took people's jobs away people left
farms and did other things like there'll
be plenty to do and begin to think about
five or ten years from now I'm just
desperate to get this office to care
about today the problem with the
industry is we completely romance
yesterday everybody loves everything
that happened in the past and we are
incredibly romantic about the future